Across the globe, followers of Islam are beginning to observe the holy month of Ramadan...
...in which believers dedicate time to reflection and prayer, fasting from sunrise to sunset.
Many of the world's Muslims, estimated to number more than one and a half billion,...
...will be immersing themselves in the Ramadan traditions...
...including reading and reciting the Koran and giving to charity.
For some it's time to head home, for others a chance to visit somewhere special.
We came to Istanbul in order to feel the unique atmosphere of Ramadan here.
The duration is a lunar month.
Most countries are observing the start of this year's holy month on Wednesday.
But for others, including parts of Africa and the Americas, Ramadan has already begun.